here's what it comes down to with ethics
it's all about the categorical
imperative it's all about what if
everybody did that is that going to make
things better or is that going to make
things awful if you want to be evil go
be evil fine
but don't do evil by accident and the
way you avoid doing evil by accident is
by sort of thinking through what if
things go wrong what if somebody was
going to use this as a weapon
[Music]
hi all and welcome to mooco's corner
mooco's corner is a show about leading a
life that feels more you in both your
life and tech career i'm your host
miyuko and invite you to come on in sit
down as usual grab something warm or hot
to drink and enjoy the show
today on the show we have mike lee
mike lee is an engineer mentor speaker
and organizer
from honolulu hawaii to silicon valley
to amsterdam with projects ranging from
delicious library and tap tap revenge to
obama 08 and amsterdam
his presentations have stretched the
balance of what can be presented at tech
conferences and his no bs business
advice has influenced makers and
entrepreneurs around the world so hi
mike how are you doing how's your week
been oh my week has been very busy i
just got stung by a wasp so that's one
to check off my list
oh goodness
are you okay everything everything good
there like you're you know i happen to
have a better drill in my bag so i took
that and i should be fine but if i fall
asleep in the middle of the interview
it's not because you're boring it's the
wasp
okay got it i'll i'll look up um
amsterdam 911 and maybe call and be like
yo my podcast guest
uh he's out and i don't know where he is
but he's somewhere in amsterdam
i hope everything turns out okay with
the wasp
i'm sure it'll be fine
yeah well i'm so so excited to talk to
you today um we were saying before the
show this is probably the first time
that i've talked to you one-on-one like
in this kind of synchronous environment
i've been a fan of yours for a long time
because i think
360 idev 2015 was my very first ever
like tech conference my very first ios
conference that i went to and you gave a
talk there uh and you gave many talks at
many other conferences that i've been to
and it's always been life-changing like
you said in your bio like you you really
do change the bounds of like what can be
given at tech conference talks and i
feel like your talks are the kinds of
talks that i wish i saw more at tech
conferences it's a lot about ethics it's
a lot about technology it's a lot of i
think the one that i saw
most recently maybe i think it was at
alt conf was about mars terraforming and
i was like
like an hour ago we were talking about
how to build table views and why
storyboards aren't bad and now we're
talking about mars terraforming so
i've always been a huge huge fan of your
talks mike thank you very much
today on the show i kind of wanted to
throw some deep
questions about life and tech and the
world and the universe at you because
these are
questions that i've been brewing in my
mind for years but have really kind of
surfaced up so um just for some
background i think like i started my
youtube channel as a way to kind of like
help people into the tech industry
especially those from underrepresented
backgrounds and kind of like really use
it as like a playground for myself also
to think about like what impact do i
want to have on the world what message
do i want to give or have people
consider who are coming into the tech
world what are things that people aren't
talking about and in that process it's
been a lot of this kind of like
like what what is technology what why do
we have technology like what makes good
technology and so
i it's been in my brain for a long time
just because i think around that time
too around 2016 2017 was when the
elections were happening in the states
cambridge analytica a lot of this stuff
about like facebook is maybe bad maybe
we shouldn't rely so heavily on social
media kind of stuff those conversations
are coming up and so
this conversation is not
super new nor is it uh uncommon
everybody who uses any sort of
technology always thinks about this
stuff but you've given talks to
engineers about it so i think actually
let's start somewhere a lot easier than
this and we'll kind of start leaning
into that in a little bit but
mike you've been a software engineer for
a long time and you've been making apps
ios apps specifically and kind of been
in this tech community and tech industry
so i kind of wanted to ask first like
mike why do you like coding and what is
it about technology that like interests
you and keeps you in the industry like
why do you keep choosing to be here and
what is it that that you know keeps you
excited about about making stuff like
this
um well i mean
i don't really like coding uh any more
than i like writing you know what i mean
it's like it hurts my hands it hurts my
head
um it hurts my relationships i mean it's
you know it's like any other kind of art
uh
sometimes it really feels like torture
but it also feels like there's kind of
something inside that needs to come out
and
you know my job is really about having
empathy for people and empathy for
machines and so i have to learn to speak
the language of the people and the
language of the machine and that's what
coding ultimately is and so it's
it's what we put up with it's it's ugly
it's awkward and just like human
language
but it's what we have if we're going to
understand each other and if we're going
to you know help each other um or at
least you know seek help in in the form
of technology you know as for what
technology is i mean it's kind of in the
term itself it's the art of science it's
basically how we
take the knowledge that we've gained
about the universe and sort of apply
that you know cash in that science and
with some engineering and get us some
cool stuff that we call technology you
know like fire was technology back in
the day right it's all about that
that application of knowledge and a
better understanding it's all about like
figuring out ways that we can sort of
put our hands on reality and shift it
around and what we can make out of that
yeah i love that's very poetic i i like
that you talk a lot about coding as
almost as an art form basically it's a
method of self-expression it's a way
it's not the
the end-all be-all um it's it's a tool
to help you get things out into the
world to create new things to lift
humanity to new heights also hearing
that you don't like coding is also very
uh it makes me feel good because i also
don't like coding and a lot of people
are always just like but you're a
software engineer i'm like yeah i don't
like coding but i like the stuff that it
makes
yeah yeah well great i thank you for
sharing that now let's just kind of get
into it so this whole thing about
technology i think like we've labeled
ourselves in the tech industry but
really it's
it's a lot about creating software is
what it is it's the software tech
industry because i don't know i just
think about like
technology is not a new concept like you
said fire was technology back in the day
wheels were technology back in the day
electricity anything that agriculture
really is technology as well and so like
the way the way that we think about
technology has definitely changed over
millennia and just her current
definition is is stuff like tick tock
and uber and
doordash and stuff like that but
i think like one of the things that
really interests me is like how do you
make good technology like what even is
good quote unquote technology i guess
when we look back at like past
inventions and innovations it's like
yeah it was good like food helped us to
heat our bodies and also like cook food
and it was like this whole new thing
that unlocked us to develop bigger
brains and and kind of make our own
civilizations and agriculture also
unlocks that as well but we're right in
the middle of the software tech industry
and we're seeing
i think especially in the last five
years the bad come out of it i've heard
a lot about just like
us as technologists sort of and
especially in the the software tech
industry can be kind of naive about how
technology can be used and how like the
best case scenario is what is thought
about when we create it but like we
sometimes don't think about the worst
case scenario
so like what do you think about that it
was a very
big question
but i wanted to hear it i think that
there is a lot of
pressure and money basically behind
giving software engineers the idea that
one stop calling yourself an engineer
you're just another person that we pay
to do things we want to
de-professionalize you we want to take
your pride away from you because an
engineer has to stick by ethics right
and we don't want us to think about
ethics they want us to do what we're
told and build what they want us to
build and not get in their way and when
we stop and say okay well what if things
don't go to plan or you know what about
the fact that every tool is also a
weapon what can we do to ameliorate that
it just irritates them uh i once had a
vc type tell me that an engineer is like
a dog and if they bark too loud you just
pull on the chain and choke them off and
it's like that's not how you treat an
engineer nor a dog
but that's how some people think
and that's what we have to sort of fight
against when we take the ownership of
what we do when we take the pride and
the responsibility for what we do when
we have honor with what we do
that's when we consider things like
ethics and
ultimately even though it irritates them
it's not just about being a goody
two-shoes doing this kind of analysis
actually ends up saving
a lot of time and money and trouble down
the road because
ethics basically is what protects us
from criminal negligence
this whole kind of concept too of ethics
because like i so i went to like a
four-year university and studied
computer science and like the school
that i went to and specifically the
program that i was part of was just like
we should practice ethics and
engineering regardless of if it's
computer science or if it's structural
engineering or mechanical engineering
aerospace engineering and i think
education programs are different now
because at the time when i took the
ethics classes that i need to it was
like trolley problem what happens if
you're standing on a cliff and there's
another person that's hurling at you and
only one of you can survive are you
supposed to get out of the way like it
was very unapplicable but can you talk
to me a little bit more about this kind
of like engineering ethics because like
i think a lot about you know if we are
the people bringing certain
ideas and concepts and functionality and
products and services to life even if
it's someone else's idea
we have the responsibility of making it
into a thing right and so
if our responsibility lies there then we
also have a responsibility to make it
well and also make sure that like these
are things that uh are
i don't know if net positive is like a
naive way to say it but we have a
responsibility towards the things that
we create right and so
like how can we think about ethics as
engineers like what do you like what
where lies the responsibility i guess
like are we
i i know that like that whole like the
analogy you gave was just like juniors
or dogs like brings me to my core
because it's like there are
organizations that really make you feel
that way and as soon as you say
something about like maybe we shouldn't
make this and like
you know we can replace you with someone
who will make it and so
it's a very interesting
i don't know like double-sided coin sort
of situation of
like we're so empowered as engineers and
yet we actually don't have any power at
all well the thing is i mean we we we do
have power in a certain sense
but it kind of depends on like i mean
what is power power is the collection
and distribution of treasure period end
of story and so we
facilitate that we can get in the way of
that
um the last time i had an ethical
dilemma it was a question of you know
opt-in versus opt-out and i just went
ahead on my own time and just made the
thing
that you would have to make so that they
would have to
you know actually tear out the ethical
stuff if they wanted to uh to to be that
way so that they couldn't even say that
like oh we didn't want to like spend an
extra time or money like they would
actually have to go through the effort
you know like i once heard that somebody
had the idea that instead of a nuclear
suitcase the nuclear codes would be
actually in somebody's body and the
president would actually have to cut
somebody open and murder them in order
to get the nuclear codes because that's
how dire the situation would have to be
to warrant that kind of action and that
sounds ridiculous until you have a
president who you kind of wish maybe had
uh
you know some more checks and balances
right i mean here's what it comes down
to with ethics
it's all about the categorical
imperative it's all about what if
everybody did that
is that going to make things
better or is that going to make things
awful
and fundamentally if
you wouldn't want somebody to do it to
you i mean and it's not even about the
golden rule because the golden rule sort
of assumes that you you know know what's
good for somebody else or that they
would want what you would want and the
point is you know leave people alone and
if you're going to bother people then
you better have a darn good reason and
they'd better be willing to participate
you know like we we have
one basic thing that we need to keep in
mind and that is informed consent
does the person actually understand what
is going to happen to them and are they
actually okay with that and that's on us
not on them it's not a matter of showing
them some 30-page document and saying
click this to get what you're after it's
a matter of if push comes to shove whose
fault is it if they didn't understand
it's our fault
if they didn't know what they were
getting into if you want to be evil go
be evil fine
but don't do evil by accident and the
way you avoid doing evil by accident is
by sort of thinking through well what if
things go wrong what if somebody was
going to use this as a weapon and that
kind of analysis is how you end up with
things like oh i don't know
not letting somebody type the same uh
you know thing into a form three times
right so that somebody can't just sit
there and uh you know use your your api
in some kind of weaponized way like just
putting some basic constraints on things
that you might not think about
because all of your energy has been
trying to get people to come in and you
haven't put any thought into how do you
keep the other kind of people out and if
you don't what kind of effect that's
going to have etc so it's that kind of
that kind of you know
enemy thinking like the best way to make
a great system is to also create the
ante system and sort of set those two
things against each other and that's
kind of what you know what ethical
thinking is about it's just sort of like
you know well let me let me think about
being evil for a second you know let's
not assume everybody has good intentions
let's actually think about it and design
things against that it's just makes it
just makes good software it's just good
good engineering sense
yeah definitely this i i like how you
said you talked about like okay think
about the best case scenario but also
think about the worst case scenario like
be the good guy and the bad guy because
at the end of the day for something as
well distributed as software where like
anybody anywhere can use it for the most
part there are like so many different
kinds of people are gonna use it that
you can't assume
where that person is coming from or what
their level of understanding is and so
you have to meet everybody where they
are i feel like is what it is because
like there are some arguments of just
like oh well we should make everybody
more technology literate there should be
classes or there should be education in
early childhood education about getting
people to really understand
how like certain systems work and how
software works and i don't know to them
to that i'm just like are you going to
teach kids what dark patterns are and
how to look out for them because
and any plan that is based on changing
human behavior is a plan that is
destined to fail you know i always tell
people like the number one rule of
business is that stop coming up with
ideas and putting them into the market
you're just wasting your time
look for the places where people are
spending time and money and find a way
for them to spend less time and less
money and then it's just a matter of
convincing them that you're not you know
full of crap and they'll definitely
you know buy into that they'll just give
you a cut of what they're saving
basically i mean that's
that's all it is
yeah totally yeah i i think i feel like
that's a really important like almost
product philosophy of just like it's not
don't find problems and solve them find
the problems where people are already
spending time and money and make it
better for them yeah look at what people
are doing don't don't assume that people
are somehow going to change they're
going to learn how to use this thing
like oh and and then tomorrow
everybody's going to be doing you know
some other thing and it's like they're
probably not they're going to just be
doing what they're doing except they're
going to be doing it in sort of the
lowest energy way that they can just
like the rest of nature
right yeah totally yeah that's really
fascinating so
i mean the fact of the matter is there
are a lot of software engineers out
there already who uh
i don't know like
one of the things that i
think about is just like
the fact that software engineers are
just you know people who are writing
code making product services and stuff
there's just been such a strong emphasis
on like it's the technology it's the
coding it's the programming language
it's the all of that that's important to
to software and stuff and
like more and more as time goes by there
is this argument of just like yeah but
it's the soft skills it's the behavioral
skills like you also just need to be not
a bad person and pleasant to work with
in order to be a good software engineer
but
like i feel like another part of that is
like if you're gonna make software if
you're gonna make stuff for other people
i feel like it's important to know
other people
better like it's almost like sometimes
i'm like maybe maybe we should all like
in order to become a software engineer
maybe this is a very like extreme
example but like maybe we should all
take
many anthropology and sociology classes
that's actually what i ended up doing
you know really oh no way i went to the
university of hawaii at four-year
university and my plan was to actually
be a doctor
and so i matriculated as a biology major
and then the
you know college of arts and sciences
basically said
no
you don't get credit for being a good
scientist as a doctor being a scientist
is a given if you want to stand out as a
doctor you have to understand people so
you need to go study anthropology
sociology linguistics learn all about
people
and that's what's going to make you a
great doctor and i didn't end up
becoming a doctor but as an engineer
it's the exact same situation
you know the only thing i use from
computer science is like you know
algorithmic efficiency calculations
other than that it's you know it's
mostly just interesting just like the
rest of that kind of you know
mathematics right
um but like you know software
engineering is really much more about
understanding how people work in the
power dynamics of people and what's
going on in the world and what you're
affecting and how you're affecting it
and where that money is coming from and
uh you know
it's yeah it's it's about basically
you know manipulating the fabric of of
reality as we know it i mean the
question of why everything suddenly is
about software is because we've gotten
hardware to the point where it's mostly
just universal and all we have to do is
talk to it and then it will do more or
less what we want and that's you know
that's what software is and then once we
can do that at sort of like the
molecular level with nano machines or
whatever then that's kind of like the
apotheosis of what we do but it's really
all about
understanding reality and and and
particularly reality as it relates to
workflows and then manipulating those
workflows the way that you manipulate
enzyme channels in a cell
uh
to you know make the cell do this or
that you know so we're sort of this
low-level machinery of the uh larger
mechanism that we're all a part of
yeah it's it's like we as people who
write code think that our our systems
and our code ends where a computer ends
but in reality it actually far extends
that where we need to be thinking about
the world as our system
like you said like how how do things
play into each other who's funding the
money like what's going on what are the
different constraints against different
kinds of people in different societies
and how does your piece of work play
into that and how does it and and really
that's that's the part that we
own of just like uh we we are part of a
bigger system actually it's not just the
code that we write and so thinking about
all of that so when you were at
university like was that one of the like
the requirements like just like being
bio of just like you have to take these
classes too well so you know pre-med was
a curriculum so it was basically a list
of uh science uh and math classes you
had to take so like i had to take
organic chemistry for example which was
a lot of fun because you got to
basically see that you know molecules
are just sort of like three-dimensional
lego and you can just kind of snap them
apart and put them back together using
various algorithms that we call
reactions and uh you can just sort of
manipulate reality at that level too
um and you know we sort of simulate that
with a bunch of switches uh you know in
a transistor set in a you know cpu and a
in a computer that we call a phone for
some reason
yeah for sure and so like i uh i don't
know i a lot of what i think about is
just like yeah maybe we should i think
about going back to school because i'm
just like i need to like learn more
about people if i'm ever gonna make
stuff that actually serves people but
i mean i'm not saying that i'm like
unique or special or anything like that
but i'm not sure you are unique and
special right we are all unique and
special that's why this is true in our
own individual way yeah that's very true
sometimes i
wonder if we all had done that of course
like
uh hindsight's 2020 there's many other
universes in which we have actually done
that
how the world would be different if we
if
as software engineers as people who
fully
own and are responsible for the
creations that we put out into the world
if we just understood people better
how would software be different i think
that if we just realized that we are all
just
individual parts of one greater thing
and that it's not about sort of me
versus you us versus them but we're sort
of all in this together and so anything
where i win and everybody else loses is
not really going to be good solution
because the big picture is kind of the
real picture
and having sort of the humility to see
yourself as one part of something much
greater
and serving that much greater purpose
rather than just being just sort of like
this one selfish actor
you know fundamentally if you don't care
about the people that you you know pass
when you walk down the street just
because you don't know them then you're
not going to worry so much if you know
what you're doing is stealing money from
them or earning their lives or messing
up their relationships but if you
actually try to feel compassion for
every single living person no matter how
awful you might think that they are
uh you can actually learn something
you know and that doesn't mean just you
know going out there you know like i'm
no idiot right i have a hard effing life
i know every awful thing that there is
out there and
you know at the end of it the only thing
that i have left is that it hasn't made
me awful
you know i i just absolutely refuse uh
to to ultimately go out uh and just say
you know yeah you know effort everybody
sucks you know hit the big red button
that destroys reality f enlightenment
like no i'm just not willing to do that
and so
you know when i for example look at a
situation and i say well if i don't do
anything then people are going to die
or be hurt or whatever
then somehow it's that's partially my
responsibility
you know and if i uh get hurt in the
process uh then that's that's just part
of it maybe that's why i'm here you know
yeah definitely
yeah how how do you think like
this is like a big question but how do
you think people can become more
compassionate how do you think people
can develop empathy for others like i
feel like that's one of the hardest
things to teach other people but
it is one of the most important things
to learn so like for someone who wants
to cultivate something like that how can
they do that so i think that this is
very important because i've actually
seen you know i've seen a psychopath try
to code and it's almost impossible
because a psychopath cannot figure out
what the machine is talking about
right the psychopath is not able to to
to imagine themselves from another
perspective they're they're sort of
stuck in their you know in their one
self they can't sort of four
dimensionally put themselves into
somebody others uh body and just kind of
imagine for a second what it might be
like to be them
and that's the fundamental exercise and
that's not a thing that you're born with
or not born with it's just a an idea
that somebody came up with this just a
meme that we have
that we can do on purpose uh through
through thought right if you can think
about uh how the computer is willing to
you know execute what it is that you
wanted to do if you can think about uh
you know tracing a tree through some
thousands of recursive instructions blah
blah blah i mean the stuff that we do
it's easy enough to think about how
somebody else might feel or what it
might be like i mean when i listen to
podcasts and i hear about something
awful happening to somebody or even
something great happening to somebody i
really try to inhabit that i really try
to close my eyes and
sort of picture that and sort of feel
that pleasantness or unpleasantness and
in doing so i learned how to not only
suffer for others
suffering but also to take joy in others
joy and so you know i no longer feel
shodden for it if somebody falls down i
don't laugh i just feel bad for them and
you know especially bad if i could have
done something to prevent it and didn't
um and if somebody feels joy i don't
feel jealous i'm just happy for them you
know because again to me it's like we're
all on the same team and
you know we're as capable of uh of of
being in tune with each other's emotions
as we are of uh ignoring or uh canceling
them out
yeah it's an interesting time to live in
right now too especially because it
feels a lot like there is this kind of
tension between individuality versus
community or like collaborative effort
kind of stuff especially with coven
coming from like i'm japanese american
and so japanese cultures are incredibly
community based or very it's not me it's
it's all of us versus right um obviously
this is an extreme and america is very
individualistic it's me over over others
and so yeah it's an interesting time in
which like we're all forced to really
reckon with like how do we actually get
through something like this together is
it by prioritizing ourselves or is it by
prioritizing others yeah so like i am in
this exact same situation i'm also
japanese-american um my family was
actually
and you know it's the same thing like
here in the netherlands where i live
it's very much i feel
where they're trying to strike this
balance between capitalism and socialism
not as in either or but as sort of like
the yin and yang that are in this kind
of opposition with each other
and we see that too much of one or the
other just becomes you know untenable
um and so it really is finding that
balance and what i have found you know
for myself most recently and i think
that you know i see sort of as the
problem in in most people you have to
learn how to truly love yourself
and once you truly love yourself then
the love for others flows from the love
of self and so many of us are in this
kind of people-pleasing mode where we
feel like we either have to you know
think of ourselves exclusively or we
have to somehow put everybody ahead of
us but there's actually a third solution
where you love yourself the most and
then it all sort of flows out from there
and then you know you don't have to let
everybody the same there's seven and a
half billion of us you can love somebody
the least but it has to start with
yourself and it has to go from there
because if you are exhausting yourself
in order to give to others you're going
to eventually
run out of energy and either become
broken or or cynical and then people are
just going to point to you and say see
if it were simply a matter of knowing
what the perfect thing to do is and then
doing it then all of this would be easy
but computing is all about having a
limited amount of resources and having
to make compromises between all kinds of
different things that we're trying to
accomplish and that goes inside the
computer as well as outside the computer
and that's true of everything in nature
everything is limited everything has
only a certain capacity everything has
only so much attention to give and
that's why
you know things are hard and that's what
we as as engineers and as people have to
constantly be sort of striking uh you
know as a balance but at the end of the
day it has to be this kind of serial
connection and not this not this either
or situation
yeah definitely if you don't mind me
asking a personal question kind of this
whole self-love thing
um
how are you able to find self-love
because you you mentioned you've been
through a lot of
i think it came from during this
pandemic i did so
much in terms of like
i really wanted to be very active and i
wanted to make the most of my time and
so i ended up taking a lot of hobbies uh
and that included like you know a lot of
baking and cooking and stuff and so i
was like producing a lot of uh you know
stuff for people and
i really kind of started to take notice
of sort of how much i felt appreciated
or not appreciated by certain people and
how much people were sort of valuing me
or not valuing me
and then i kind of started realizing
well how much am i valuing myself
you know and then i kind of started like
you know thinking in terms of that i'm
like you know like what do i actually
want right now you know what do i
actually feel uh you know good about and
you know obviously i can you know
go on top of that and say okay well yes
that's what i want but that would be uh
you know a very dickish move because i
also want these people to still respect
me tomorrow so the compromise is you
know but it starts with you know knowing
what you actually uh what you actually
want
and a lot of that comes down to like you
care about the stuff that you care about
and like you might as well admit that
you might as well put that forward you
know and if somebody says you know well
like why you know why can't it be my way
it's like why should it be your way why
should it be anybody's way right like we
all have our particular way and and you
kind of realize
and i think this is really what it comes
down to the problem is when you let your
light shine when you just you just be
yourself your actual unfiltered self
then there are other people who are
going to be like oh my god your light is
blinding me please turn it down and
you're going to feel embarrassed and
ashamed and you're going to want to you
know turn that down and not be yourself
and conform to how you think people want
you to be but what you don't understand
is that beyond those are the the the
dozens the the thousands who see your
light shining and that's giving them
permission you know for their light to
shine like i'm definitely not the first
person to say that but that is
100 the reality of things and that is
what it really comes down to is just
being like i am going to authentically
be myself and anybody who has a problem
with it is that is their problem and and
it doesn't mean that i can't improve i'm
improving myself every day you know
that's the catch when everybody says be
yourself what they mean is you can't
fake it be yourself and if yourself
sucks then work on that
right you know learn ethics learn how to
play the guitar uh you know learn how to
process your emotions and uh you know be
yourself but really be yourself don't
don't be fake that's not gonna get
anybody anywhere
yeah definitely it's it's such a hard
thing to be honest with yourself to be
yourself and some people i think have a
difficulty figuring out like what is
myself like what who is me but i feel
like when you start it's literally like
layers of anonymous when you start
peeling back you start to see who you
are and you'll see the good and the bad
some others to just like having
responsibility for the stuff you make i
think there's a responsibility you have
to have to yourself to face the great
parts and the terrible absolute like
bad parts of yourself but figuring out
what those things are and realizing what
your constraints are
like you've kind of like analogized many
times like if you think of yourself
almost like a system if you're working
in that kind of mode of just like here
are the certain things that i have to
work with here's problems that there are
i have to work on those things let's
identify them let's figure out what
resources i have i feel like that's when
the real magic happens and so be
yourself to me is just like
i don't know it feels so much more
like that phrase is very like it's like
oh if i'm just if i just exist i i am
myself but in reality i feel like
there's just so much more work
uh it's it's more just like like
i don't know become yourself maybe as a
more active be the best version of
yourself really you know
yeah yeah definitely yeah at the end of
the day you're not a fixed thing and if
you declare yourself to be a fixed thing
you're going to pretty much immediately
stop being that thing like you have to
see yourself as this kind of ongoing
project and if you say well i mean i did
that but i'm not a bad person it's like
well obviously you are a bad person
because you did a bad thing
right like you are the things that you
do and if you take responsibility for
yourself the things that you say the
things that you do and how those have
you know effects on other people whether
you intended them to or not i mean that
is also a part of self-love yeah
definitely i think a part of like this
whole kind of like how do you face bad
stuff whether that's within you or
within society i feel like sometimes
that invokes fear too because it is
scary to look at the dark parts
about reality so like how how do you
think how have you slash how do you
think others can like face that fear
because i think it inherently takes
courage to look look at those things
because it is a lot easier to look at
the good things and the bright shiny
things in life but in order to
make good things in order to be
responsible for those things you have to
look at those bad things so how can
people address the fear i think that i
think fear comes from dishonesty
honestly because once you're dishonest
then you're afraid that people are going
to find out that you're dishonest and
then
you know you have that that fear
and i think that that you know that is
what everything ultimately boils down to
obviously there's like the fear of death
etc right but i think even the fear of
death is to a certain extent the fear of
not having lived an honest life you know
i think that like the way that you deal
with fear is to shine a light on it and
to see what it is because the unknowing
is always going to be uh worse than the
actual thing itself because as you know
as awful as it is it is what it is and
you can you know you can deal with it
you can start to uh wrap your mind
around it
but when you don't know what it is then
it becomes basically everything that it
could be and that's so much worse
and not only that but every bit of
energy you expend into dealing with the
everything that it could be is not
really going into dealing with the thing
that it actually is
and so you're much better off just you
know facing that fear
uh you know sort of head-on and if uh
you know there's something you can do
about it then uh then great and you can
get started um and maybe you need to ask
for help and maybe you need to uh you
know admit some things and maybe you
need to let some things go you know
whatever it is but uh you're not going
to be able to move forward and
ultimately being stuck is is going to be
worse than you know whatever it is
you're going to have to go through to
get to the other side in i think almost
all situations
yeah definitely i like i i only read
like russian literature in high school
and stuff but it reminds me of just like
russian literature a lot of is is just
like human being human is suffering
everything is about suffering everything
sucks and everything's bad but maybe and
i used to think like oh my gosh that's
such like a pessimistic negative way of
looking at life but in reality i feel
like the lesson that it i'm taking away
from it now is just like
yeah like there is there is bad parts
and it there is a lot of suffering but
it's much better to face it and to deal
with it and work through it and
recognize it than to ignore it
completely yeah i think when like as i
get older and older and i know myself
better i realize how important it is to
my health to be authentic and honest
with myself
uh just because it was so easy to not be
that way i think like especially when
you're younger and you care about what
other people think and you're a minority
or you stick out in some way whatever
that might be
but it's just like i don't know i think
in order to be authentic and honest it's
not always going to be dazes and
butterflies it's sometimes going to be
death and wretched terrible things but
yeah absolutely absolutely yeah um but
then it's like otherwise it's just a you
know a hidden festering wound
you know yeah something bad isn't gonna
go away just because you don't admit
that it's there
yeah for sure
okay so tying this back again to kind of
the software engineering thing too maybe
i don't know if most people have
experienced this but i think there comes
a certain point in every software
engineer's life of just like this feels
bad this feels like not the right thing
to do i feel like leadership product
management whoever else is deciding
certain things it just doesn't feel good
maybe it's another engineer or something
like that and i think like
some people find their courage and speak
up and sometimes good things happen
sometimes people speak up and nothing
happens happens at all other people are
just afraid because they have a lot to
lose um for speaking up and stuff but i
think one of the core parts too
to all of that is some software
engineers definitely work on very dire
things that are a matter of life and
death like if you work in the defense
con defense industry if you work on like
health tech sort of stuff like
definitely people can die as a result of
your work but there are a lot of us
you know myself included who don't work
on things that feel as dire i think
social media is a really good example of
just like at the end of the day you know
a lot of people can argue that it's just
like i'm connecting one person to
another what's so bad in that but then
things happen like election tampering
and stuff like that right so like how
can people who work in situations that
don't feel dire understand the weight of
their work when nobody else does how can
they work through that i guess like if
you if you encounter that sort of
situation where you're just like i
should say something but i i don't know
if i don't know if it's even warranted
to say i think that what should they do
you
well okay for me uh i always try to
approach things from a place of
understanding
i want to know you know if this thing
seems wrong to me
then why are all of these people going
along with it you know what's actually
going on here and i think that in trying
to pursue that
and then trying to understand i mean
i've unraveled whole companies just by
not understanding what the heck it was
they were building and then asking
everybody until it turned out that
nobody understood what the heck they
were building and everybody thought that
everybody else knew what they were
building and they weren't building
anything
and you know if you actually get it to
the point where somebody kind of does uh
take ultimate responsibility for it uh
or tells you you know stop uh asking
questions or whatever uh you know then
you have your answer and then you sort
of have to ask yourself you know
uh
what is this situation here is this
something where i'm in mortal danger and
i need to get away or is this basically
a responsibility that i didn't deserve
but that has been put into my you know
into my lap right it's like if you're
walking down the street and somebody
asks you to take a picture of them with
their family uh it's kind of a a dick
move just to be like nah screw you you
know like we all kind of agree that
that's a nice thing to do there's no
reason why you should do that it's just
kind of you know it's your dharma it's
just fallen onto you
and a lot of times those are the
problems that get sent our way whether
they're happening at work or whether
they're happening out in the world all
of a sudden it seems like like it or not
this problem has been put in front of me
and because i'm the only one here who
seems to be able to do something about
it
maybe that means that it falls to me to
do something about it and you know
make sure that you kind of like you know
again check in with yourself first check
in with your you know your partner your
number two your best friend your your
your boss or whoever it is
uh and and and go from there document
everything for what it's worth you know
evidence is always better than hearsay
and uh you know even if that if there's
nothing else you can do
uh just document things you know if i
for example uh you know i'm obviously
much more sensitive to like racial
things uh especially asian things uh
that people say uh and sometimes you
know people will say something that i
think is a little inappropriate and i
might you know take a screenshot of it
you know and then maybe i'll go talk to
them or maybe i'll bring it up or
whatever and i'll just keep track of
those uh of those reactions because
you know first of all later on i want to
be able to go back and look at them for
myself because half the time they're not
half as bad as i as i thought that they
were in retrospect so there's also that
but also times it's like i just want to
see you know maybe there's a pattern
established or something like that like
you just never know um it's the same
thing as like you know uh you know if
you're gonna go somewhere that you don't
usually go tell somebody that you're
going in case something happens to you
right it's like the same basic idea um
you know make sure you check in with
people that kind of a thing you know i
think that that's uh that's the best
sort of basic uh basic framework of of
what to do when you find yourself in a
situation where you don't think that uh
you know that that thing should be
happening and you know
i can't necessarily say that you should
do you know what i would do because you
know i think we've seen the consequences
of you know me sometimes taking that
stand but at the same time
uh i don't look back with regret on
you know on those times uh that i did
the right thing
you know no matter how much it cost me
yeah and the right thing looks different
for everybody for sure but i think
doing your due diligence documenting
things trying to empathize with other
people checking in with yourself i feel
like is is one of the best things that
you can do when you when you get into
those situations get some sleep that's
another one you know
uh definitely take it get a good night's
sleep before you do make any decisions
you know what i mean
definitely that's great advice well hey
mike i know we're coming up to the end
of the time thank you so much for being
on the show where can people find you
online to follow you to hear about your
talks to watch your talks where can they
get sure if you go to my website that's
murmurs like mur dot mu dot rs or lemurs
which is ali.mu.rs
either one will get you to uh to my
content
awesome if y'all are ever looking for
some incredibly thought-provoking talks
then definitely check out literally any
and all of mike's talks because i will
promise you you will not regret it you
can also listen to this episode of the
muko's coroner podcast by checking it
out on your favorite podcasting app of
your choice
all right thank you so much mike for
being on the show today and thank you
all for listening
[Music]